we want you to understand that you may
have to outsource your development to a
developer as part of that you should
have a solid understanding of what it
takes to build an app having a good
foundation will allow you to make sound
business decisions over time you may
also have big ideas for what you want
your app to accomplish so we want you to
understand what comes standard in a
platform versus what would need to be
custom built the latter will take a lot
more work to implement we should
probably go over some vocabulary our
next to text nodes will cover some basic
vocabulary you should be familiar with
before you talk with an engineer